what's up everyone hello welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan Saki on we
are Ron Vargas producing and directing
we got Robert Griffis as our guest
what's that Robert it's good to be here
great to see you didn't too long even
though it's only been a week or more
Robert Griffith is running for governor
of California in 2018 he also ran for
president 2016 mm-hmm
he's got a great background banking
little good interest in politics we're
gonna talk about some of these ideas
that are very unique that are different
that are strategic we're gonna see
exactly how we can implement them into
the world maybe inspire people to care
more about them so let's talk let's talk
about this journey so what what actually
uh what got you here to today like where
where were you when you you know you are
at Stanford and then you got into
banking so maybe tell us a bit about
that and where add to politics yeah well
it actually started my first clear
memory was when I was seven sitting in
front of the television watching States
on a map turned blue and red and it was
Jimmy Carter and Gerald Ford in 76 and I
was absolutely mesmerised my parents
were talking about it and even got into
an argument because my dad changed his
mind on who he voted for he voted for
Carter even though he's for the most
part of a Republican and I've just had
the bug for politics probably before
then but that's my first clear memory
and I've always been political but I
never really got involved in politics
till about 2011 for the 2012
presidential race and then you know I
ended up running in 16 so it's really
taken flight so from 7 until you know
2016 what were those kind of you know as
you're measuring economic systems and
you're really studying them and you're
and you're getting used to figuring out
what new strategies could be implemented
what what what within that economics in
the political span between the age of 7
and 2016 were kind of like the
big Hoss yeah well you know my parents
were Republicans and I thought of myself
as a Republican and I've been thinking
about that saying that if you're if
you're young and not a Democrat you have
no heart but if you're old and not a
Republican you have no brain and when I
was young I had much more of a brain
than a heart is one way I look at it so
I was very interested in economics
problem-solving going about things
logically but I was less in touch with
my heart and emotions and people I was a
little bit more objective which led me
to studying systems and information
engineering at the University of
Virginia as an undergraduate minoring in
economics and the like but I went to a
College Republicans meeting with my
roommate who was involved in that
organization and I quickly found out I
was not a Republican I said something at
that meeting and you could hear a pin
drop I just I just walked out of that
meeting going wow I'm not a Republican
so what am i What did he say do you
remember well a friend of mine who was
about 15 or 16 but a first-year student
at the University of Virginia was
running for student council president he
was kind of a genius an engineering
student he would always wear a metallica
shirt or anthrax or some other heavy
metal he had a thick Vietnamese accent
the long Tron was his name and he
considered himself an anarchist and I
didn't really know what that was I just
thought he was cool he was smart I liked
him and I advocated for this anarchist
at a college Republicans meeting and
they looked at me like I was from
another planet yeah because I said
something about you know let's really
[ __ ] with the system and and they were
just like you know Republicans just my
language and and just this sort of
energetic youthful approach was not were
these guys mostly men were coming from
and so I kind of wandered in the
wilderness and eventually found myself
philosophically drawn towards you know I
read some mine Rand and and I eventually
you know got involved
yeah I registered eventually as a
libertarian voted libertarian and got
somewhat involved in the Libertarian
Party in 2011 and 12 and then found
myself running as a candidate for
president in that party in 16 so when
you say things like you know let's buck
with the system that's that to me
actually is good you're Dino you're
thinking outside of the box you're
thinking about ways to to be eccentric
or unusual rather than the whole 99
sheep walk in one direction well you
want to be that black sheep that walks
in the other that's been a reoccurring
theme on our show we talk about that a
lot with our guests what were some of
those strategies that you were boiling
in as you became libertarian as you
started you know running for governor
and everything and for president what
were you thinking about the economic
change that you wanted to make and what
are some of those well I I think you
know the Libertarian Party which is very
small very poorly funded it's all
volunteer they put all their money into
putting the presidential candidate on
the ballot in 50 states and so they
don't really get anybody elected and
they're not they don't have the best
track record of attracting good
candidates so but but they're principals
they have principals they call
themselves the the party of principle
and their principles are very simple and
I like to keep it simple stupid as they
say JIS s and now sometimes they make
leaps with those principles the policies
that the general public isn't ready for
or at least not now and some of those
responsible or some of those who keep it
simple stupid czar things like personal
responsibility yeah I mean the the ethos
is don't hurt people and don't take
their stuff you know or you know don't
kill and don't steal if you want to
refer to the Ten Commandments yeah for
people who who are religious in this
country and and I think what makes the
libertarians different as they apply
those principles not just to the general
public I think most people would agree
to those two principles yeah but there's
a bit of a red peeling that the
government is
actually you know may not be following
them and that's where I think the
Libertarian Party is a black sheep
politically and they say very
challenging confrontational sometimes
things about taxation or warfare yeah
they're the drug war that sort of thing
and they've been out ahead and they've
been right on things like like marriage
equality and you know we basically have
legalized marijuana in the state of
California now that's a ballot measure
the past and 16 so I think their
principles are good and I think spending
some time in that party and more
importantly in that philosophy as has
really you know I'm clear with myself
and I can be clear to the public with I
think simple principles that most people
would say are reasonable and and and it
allows me to challenge the political
establishment and mess with it to use a
different word than the word I used
earlier yeah and really kind of think
outside the box and be creative instead
of this politics as usual in the
division you know between the main two
parties you know my party the Democratic
Party which I'm now in and the
Republican party that's that's kind of a
tired old fight yeah
so as you're messing with it and
tinkering with it maybe tell us a bit
about this this banking this banking
background this economic interest sure
well what brought me to California was
Stanford's right after the University of
Virginia I went I worked a summer in DC
for a Beltway bandit and and then I in
in the telecom essentially for for the
Armed Forces and and then I I started
school at Stanford and fall of 91
majored in engineering economic systems
a department that's now called
decision Science and I got a job with a
bank that became Providian financial
which was late much later on acquired by
WaMu which fell in the housing crisis of
2008 so that firms assets are now part
of
organ chase but I was in the banking
industry for about ten years and did
just about mostly credit card which was
a booming business government and /
vidiian was a sister company to Capital
One they were founded by the same group
of people just half of them founded Cap
one in Richmond Virginia and the other
half founded Providian which was at one
time the third largest credit card bank
in the country and the most profitable
profits after taxes even approaching a
billion dollars a year I mean serious
serious money and so what as you're
doing all this immersion into credit
card and into banking what were some of
the things that maybe boiled up to the
surface for you that you thought were
really important to this and and with
this parlay until libertarianism what
we're kind of mm-hmm yeah I mean there
was a professor at Stanford who taught a
course that I took called a voluntary
social system where this was a society
where all interactions were voluntary
consensual and ideally peaceful or there
you know consequences for activity that
wasn't peaceful that was forceful or
violent and he never used the word
libertarian he did he wanted to be very
apolitical about it and analytical like
a scientist yeah he was a decision
scientist and you know in banking I
learned the importance of making a
profit for shareholders and the
employees were shareholders very much so
but also serving the customer was was a
really important lesson because you you
don't serve the customer you won't have
customers so I learned the agency of a
company was to serve its employees its
shareholders and its customers and the
general public so so Providian we did a
lot of charitable work especially in the
Bay Area and Louisville Kentucky where
we had significant operations and also
we had a formula like this was a bank
run by engineers like a we hired a lot
of people from Stanford and after I
started recruiting at UVA we hired over
a hundred people from UVA you know a
whole 3,000 miles away yeah the
president asked me Rob where do we get
more people like you
we're not getting enough out of Berkeley
in Stanford mm-hmm I was like well I
learned more at UVA than I did at
Stanford so boom we started hiring there
so we you know we applied what we called
the formula and just optimize and
maximize profits as well as serving
customer needs and so we were very
profitable but that Bank made a few
classic blunders and and that's why
they're they're essentially a part of
Chase today but 10 years in banking was
enough and it was a bit too mechanical
it is and how does it want even balance
between maximizing profits for
shareholders and providing customers
with what they need well you have to do
both to survive and that's what all
successful companies do Microsoft
wouldn't have made Bill Gates a
billionaire
had it been a bad operating system bad
software and so forth so the sort of
idyllic capitalist and the best sense of
the word as opposed to the poor sense of
what capitalism can be is you serve your
customer the customer is in charge not
the company and if you serve your
customer best give them the best product
or service at the lowest price and what
Providian did well is they serve people
who had had bankruptcies and couldn't
get credit cards elsewhere and they
helped rebuild people's credit and they
did it better than anybody yeah that's
really important we helping people
helping them rebuild their credit yeah
now okay so now we're you know in 2016
the there wasn't there was both
California Governor run as well in 2016
as well as the presidential run well in
11 and 12 I helped out Gary Johnson I
discovered him actually as a Republican
standing near Ron Paul and on a debate
stage in 2011 and I just really liked
him even though a you know to the extent
yeah I was a libertarian at that time I
just a lot of the candidate is you got
the candidate and I just liked Gary at
that time better than Robbie I supported
his campaign got his campaign of
speaking engagement at Stanford Business
School and that gave me a taste of it
and then in 16 January of 16 which was a
little late in the game which is why I
wasn't able to mount a a serious
campaign but I I showed up at the
National Convention in Orlando on
Memorial Day weekend in 2016 as a
presidential candidate filed with the
FEC did all the requirements and I got
votes nominating votes on on the
Saturday but but I didn't have enough to
be in the c-span debates or in the final
Sunday ballot but I was hey it's a small
party and I knew Gary Johnson I know
John Mac I still know Gary Johnson I
know John McAfee I know Austin Peterson
who's running for Senate as a Republican
in Missouri and so it was a great
experience to get my feet wet in
politics a national convention and I was
in the thick of it on the floor helping
out the other candidates when I was no
longer in and they were and I was you
know I had some really positive
interactions with Austin Peterson who
finished second to Gary so what are some
of these what actually occurs behind the
drapes this is very interesting at the
national convention in Orlando it was
fascinating it's one of the best weeks
of my life
politics to me is almost spiritual
endeavor and the people who were there
were so inspired they paid with their
own money to be there and to be
delegates they were passionate about
candidates and principles and policies
and it's very important to everybody
that that we as a party picked the right
person and and there was no obvious
choice and it took two ballots before
Gary you know won but it was just so
great I I had connected mostly with
libertarians through social media I
didn't really know a lot of them even
though there are a lot
them in the Bay Area but to get together
with about a thousand people of a
political ideology there was really more
about people at that point than
principle and the competition was fierce
and and it was really important to me
and I think everybody else there that we
we picked the best ticket possible which
I don't think we did so the National
Convention was just for the libertarian
for choice for 2016 yeah
Memorial Day weekend of 16 in Orlando
just a week or two before the pulse
light Club shooting it and you don't
think that you picked the right no I did
not vote for Gary Johnson or his
preferred vice-presidential candidate
governor weld of Massachusetts two
former Republican mayors and they're
great guys but it was furred awesome I
actually voted for Austin twice and I
voted for another gentleman whose name
escapes me and I apologized they're not
thinking of him at the moment but I met
pretty much everybody who has anybody in
that movement at that convention so it
was a real that's good baptism for me
and it was hard work but it was fun and
thrilling and the taste for that yeah I
started telling people I'll run for
president you know in a much more
serious way in 2020 and then and that's
what people started to suggest running
for governor of California which I'm
doing on the way yeah so what is what is
the process for the both the governor
and the president how does one even
consider this whole process what do you
need to do you need to apply with with a
commission and then you need to get
signatures what is this like yeah well
for president it was actually very easy
with the Libertarian Party or is it the
major parties I can't even imagine what
that takes you know you've got to win
the nomination you've got to go through
a long primary it takes a lot of money
you need to be established in those
parties and I'm fairly well established
in the Libertarian Party now and could
go back but I'm a Democrat and then sort
of right now there's no
looking back but for governor there was
quite a bit of work there's a lot of
forms to fill out there's a filing you
either pay about a four thousand dollar
filing fee which is about two percent of
the governor's salaries how they do that
or you gather I think it's up to about
eight thousand signatures about fifty
cents a signature but then once you pay
that you have you know basically four
weeks together if you haven't gathered
signatures already you need another
sixty five for first for nominating
signatures and and and I did gather
signatures for that I actually paid the
filing fee as opposed to gather 8,000
signatures they just thought it was more
economic but I went out and gathered a
lot and brought more than half of the
signatures myself and and that was a
great walk the street talked to people
on the street yeah because there's
there's nothing more real than trying to
ask somebody's signature yeah and and as
the candidate I I was a lot more
successful than my volunteers because
people really appreciated being able to
ask me some questions and you get to
hear what they want as well from their
candidates you get to learn from that
and then they get to learn from what you
want to build so okay so then a filing
fee or $8,000 things just for keio 8000
series and then sixty-five more to get
on on the ballot which i am officially
on the ballot I got the letter from Alex
Padilla Secretary of State Wednesday
last week and it was put it was
officially announced all the candidates
for governor how many are there now I
believe it's about 25 but it's really
only ten from the two major parties yeah
myself and some Democrats and probably a
bit and there's about four or five
Republicans and maybe five or six
Democrats and then there's a lot of
Peace and Freedom green couple of
libertarian gentlemen ya know at least
one of them mm-hmm so then so then what
actually happened so yeah June 5th is
the voting day June 5th is the open
primary and to me that's for all the
marbles because with 25 candidates
regardless of party like the parties
don't get to choose who's on the
November
they don't even get to choose who's on
the June ballot but the top two
vote-getters of all the statewide
offices and in the local ones as well
are the only two to appear on the
November ballot according to this open
primary which some people call jungle
primary watch which only exists in I
believe Louisiana and California
to my knowledge it could be another
state or two what would it be otherwise
instead of the jungle normally the
primary on June 5th only Republican
voters could vote to choose which
Republican appears on the November
ballot yeah but what it is now is it's
open to everybody all 25 of us and the
top two and only the top two appear on
the November ballot and this this is
what's very I think undemocratic about
this open primary law in California is
there are no write ins allowed in
November so June 5th is everything the
top two and in 16 we had Kamala Harris
and another woman both of them Democrats
were on the ballot in November for
Senate the United States Senate Kamala
Harris one over the other Democrat but a
lot of Republicans were scratching their
heads going I have to choose between two
Democrats yeah so in this state the
Democrats dominate and and most pundits
are picking you know that it will be two
Democrats for governor as well which
could be they're you know they're a
couple of Republican candidates that are
trying to play second so so after this
jungle phase then the top two so you
only vote for one in January and June
fifth and then then the top two
vote-getters show up in November
so normally across the states there's
only Republicans come and vote for only
Republican and Democrats would only come
and vote for only one of the Democrats
and then the top two would show up on
the ballot actually only one from each
party yeah so in the old days you'd have
one Republican one Democrat one
libertarian one green and peace and
freedom and so on and then you'd have
about half a dozen on the ballot in
November
whereas now it's too
and you can you know very frequently
with California you have two Democrats
yeah she's from okay all right so so for
me it's June 5th is everything yeah if I
if I finish top two then I got five
months to just beat whoever else is on
the ballot you know could be gavin
newsom for example all right so what are
some of the policies that you want to
bring okay well my two biggest ones and
a lot of this is I you know I thought of
these ideas myself but I found them
being done elsewhere so these these are
not unique ideas but they are unusual
for politics and and the first one had
to do with the state's debt which most
politicians won't even acknowledge I
asked the two Republican candidates
about the state death and it's really
they didn't even think about it they
don't have any plans for it but the
state is over two trillion dollars in
debt if you include the counties and the
interest on that that is over a hundred
billion dollars a year which eats up
more than twenty percent of our budget
so the economists and the engineer and
the problem-solver and me sees that 20
percent budget and that two trillion
dollars but none of that principle is
being paid down it's going to the moon
its astronomical just like the federal
debt and if nothing else I know I can
bring to the attention to the state of
California that over twenty percent
other tax dollars are paying interest on
a debt and none of their tax dollars are
paying down the principal because in
Sacramento politics as usual is spend
more than you take in and tax revenue
and run up this debt which is now just
two trillion dollars as a sum so obscene
it can never be paid so I saw that as an
opportunity I was like aha
I want to make that debt go away so I
have a plan to make the debt go away
including a hundred billion dollars a
year in interest which is eating up 20%
of our budget
we get rid of that we won't need these
gas taxes that everybody is complaining
about because that's what they passed
and and not the most straightforward and
fair manner to keep a balance its budget
because states have to balance they're
not like the federal government who can
not balance and then just use the
federal reserve money to cover the gap
states if you know they can't go
bankrupt they have to keep their head
above water we're all waking up every
day I'm just thinking about how am I
gonna make my money how am I gonna eat
my food what am I gonna go to sleep is
my sexual partner beautiful enough you
know this is these are things that we
survival survival so the last thing that
comes to people's minds is our state is
in a two trillion dollar deficit it's
hard to think about it is and it's very
abstract to think about two trillion
dollar deficit what the hell is that so
okay so over the last couple of decades
we've spent more than we've brought in
via tax dollars driving us into a
deficit having two trillion dollars with
the debt and we spend 20% of the current
budget well just 140 billion a year at
the state level and including the
counties and you know it gets up to
about 200 250 billion we spend then we
spend 20% of 115 bill well it's it's
really yeah it's these numbers are a
little larger but to keep them around
the state as a whole including counties
and municipalities you're looking at
about 500 billion dollar in budgets and
about a hundred billion of that paying
interest on debts and not even the
principal which is no principles being
just crazy it is it's irresponsible it
is it's so so that okay so now how do we
take the debt and how do we say that
okay the debt is something that we are
no longer responsible for because we're
going to take this other 20% of our
taxpayer dollars and we're gonna fund it
into California's economic growth or so
how do we how do we do that well it's
complex problem it's a hard problem and
we're paying through it through the nose
in a way that's intractable right 20%
and growing to trillion and growing so
we have to just say no we have to put
our foot down and voters have not had
anybody to vote for who's going to put
their foot down and say no to debt no to
interest no to irresponsible spending
more than you take in and I'm the guy to
do that so I would restructure that debt
tell us about them not unlike a
bankruptcy but it's not a bankruptcy at
the most confronting it's that we're not
gonna pay all of it matter of fact we
need to figure out how much of it we're
gonna pay and how much of it we're not
gonna pay we but the bottom line is we
need to make it go away we need to pay
it down or just write it off and make
make it go away and make that 20 percent
and growing hit go away and
restructuring it and you know this is
somewhat like Bernie Sanders saying he
wanted to forgive the over one trillion
dollars in student loan that is
strangling so many educated people in
this country who were saddled with
student loan debt they can't pay and
can't write off in a bankruptcy but I
think with Bernie Sanders people asked
him well what does that look like what
about these banks that loan the trillion
dollars what about them and and he
didn't really go that far into the
economics and the mathematics of it so
to me there is a moral and ethical issue
of who gets paid and who doesn't there
is an economic and financial issue which
is look we need to clean up the state's
finances but how do we do it without
hurting anybody
or hurting people the least and then
there's the political question because
if the people who don't get paid
influence the elections
well no candidate who says this and is
going to hurt the interests that have a
say unfortunately in the election so if
I were to hurt california's voters or
hurt california state employee
by not paying them on their bonds well
they're not going to vote for any
candidate who's gonna you know suggest
restructuring or even defaulting on some
of those so you know my calculus around
who gets paid and who doesn't is if you
live in California if you are a human
being as opposed to an institutional
investor like a bank or a hedge fund or
a government so the more human you are
the poorer you are and the closer to
California you live the more you're
going to get paid and an example I
always use is a couple of grandparents
you know seniors who have maybe you know
probably higher than average retirement
savings like say $100,000 what if they
have every penny in California bonds
I'm not going to default a dime on them
they're gonna get every penny of
principle every penny of interest
whereas a large hedge fund in the
hundreds of billions of dollars and I
don't know it could be China Russia
Brazil and you know the theory it could
be in the United States but if they
owned ten million in California bonds
you know my first approach to them would
be would you please donate those to the
citizens of California and help us get
out of debt so the first pass would be
voluntary and choice driven like let's
all work together to help but at some
point there could be some large rich
institutional investors where the loss
would essentially be what I call taking
a haircut you know a hedge fund that's
so enormous that has an amount of
California bonds who can afford a loss
you know grandma and grandpa can't
afford to lose a hundred thousand they
can't afford to lose ten thousand
they're gonna get paid but a huge hedge
fund where ten million in California
bonds is like a drop in the bucket you
know they're they're investors they know
when they invest in corporate bonds or
even government bonds and
or Nations that there's no 100% return
so if they don't agree to donate those
bonds in other words they would offer to
do not redeem them but if they don't
take that offer and if when push comes
to shove we've got to default on either
a fraction or possibly the entirety of
bonds but we would do this on a
case-by-case basis so the important
thing to me is that no not a hair on the
head of a human being gets hurt by this
restructuring of bonds human beings get
paid super-rich large institutional
investors that can afford to take a bit
of a haircut on their California bonds
you know that's how we would do it
you know we'd do it very humanely and
because there's no easy way to make
two-plus trillion dollars disappear
somebody's gonna have to take a loss but
this month this debt I don't believe is
legitimate the California citizen and
voter has not authorized two trillion
dollars in debt I think most citizens
don't even know about it or that the
interest I talked to two Republican
candidates for governor and they didn't
even know they had no plans for this it
just wasn't on their radar well I'm a
scientist I'm an engineer I'm an
economist and 20% of the budget just
jumped right out at me and I said okay
oh it's it's based on a debt that is in
some ways illegitimate not authorized by
the people well we need to fix that and
so so restructuring that debt is my
answer to it and I think it's possible
to make that two trillion down to zero
by the end of a four-year term and we
could restructure and you know default
as much as 50 to 60 percent of it in the
first year and that would save the state
fifty to sixty billion dollars a year
and you don't need a gas tax you can
actually repeal it a gas tax has hurt
the poor more than anybody the poor pay
all the taxes that's one myth there's
this myth that you can soak the rich in
taxes and the taxes people who know know
that investors and business owners have
loopholes
they pay no income taxes and business
owners paid no more than 20% federal and
state whereas employees which is most of
us we pay twenty to sixty percent in
federal and state income taxes that's
just income taxes so this gas tax is a
tax on the poor it's a tax on the
vulnerable and I want to be a candidate
who's not looking out for the rich
necessarily in the special interests
only but you know I want to help out the
common person the average Californian
who works hard or just struggles to
survive the single mom with three kids
and I have another plan to help
everybody as well let's let's before we
get there let's unpack this more because
the truth are so interesting yeah
there's there's the whole let's start
about it let's start with it from the
end of what you said which is that is it
true that poor people paid the majority
poor and middle class pay majority of
all the to earning wages who earn wages
pay because that's about what 90 plus
percent of people are either poor middle
class people so because of that then
those that that's where a majority of
the taxpayer dollars comes from is that
larger group of people
hmm okay yeah there are very few people
that are making a hundred thousand or
more per year or hundreds of thousands
either a lot of married couples where
one or both partners make a hundred
grand or more and you need that to
afford to live in the Bay Area or parts
of Los Angeles some of those people are
paying marginal income tax rates of up
to sixty percent but most of us are down
around the twenty to thirty twenty to
forty and that's where a huge amount of
the revenue there just aren't many
people making five hundred thousand
dollars a year yeah so you just there's
just not much money there the tax base
is the people who make anywhere from
fifteen thousand a year you know to 80
or 100 that's where almost all the money
is and then doing things like putting a
tax on gas or on other basic commodities
that that group of people really uses a
lot is takes away from their paycheck to
paycheck lifestyle
as sales taxes in particular really soak
the poor and gas taxes either directly
or indirectly that's you know cuz a rich
person another ten cents a gallon or
forty cents a gallon with diesel is is
it's not you're gonna make cause them
pain whereas the small business owner
who's got a bunch of trucks making
deliveries they're taking a bath huge
yeah okay so then let's unpack the first
part of the point which was that it's
even possible in the first place to get
rid of trillions of dollars of debt to
default on it in him so what what Bernie
proposed to forgive student loan debt
was very very interesting but like you
said who pays for it right and and it's
the same question that you brought up
which is who would pay for your
forgiveness that you plan for the who
who is in like you directed who owns the
bonds is the question is it uh is it the
mom pas they own the bonds of war is it
the hedge fund that owns the bonds
California bonds so okay so as we unpack
that more let's say that you know amical
amicably we get people to donate their
bonds and then that's step one maybe
step two is the ones that refuse to
because they want to they also have to
deal with their margins and their bottom
lines and they don't want to just donate
the their ten million dollar of the
California bonds how do you tell them
that well whether or not you want to
we're going to do this because we need
to grow California well we have the
willpower to do it like I have the
willpower to do it and it takes a lot of
willpower to say I'm gonna default on
some bonds because frankly it may even
be you could run into legal issues there
but you know I'm running on this as my
top issue so if I get elected governor
and I take office on January 9th of
night 2019
then I will have a mandate on this issue
and the people will have spoken and so
and the people get what they want in a
democracy and in the ideal sense of the
word so you'd you propel a vote on this
I would I will go to the slab on this
and I believe in it so strongly that you
know I I don't want this to be too soft
of a line yeah we need to show some
moral fortitude to deal with real
economic problems and we need to show
some real political courage like I'm not
a career politician you know I don't
have to answer to to any political party
necessarily and I just want to do what's
right for the people and and I think the
people have spoken to that you can see
that in the success of a Bernie Sanders
or even a Donald Trump who defeated the
Republican establishment and then the
Democratic establishment in the form of
Hillary and I think people are tired of
politics as usual and they they want to
hear a unique voice who is actually
addressing the real problems instead of
just playing the game
yeah man 20% of the budget is crazy
damn that's so much money that is just
paying interest not even the principle
it just seems like such a waste how can
we direct that towards education towards
reducing suffering towards flourishing
California and all of its different ways
that's really important to address and
to get people inspired by so ok talk to
us about the second ok so I think one
other thing I want to do is a lot of
times voters look rather cynically at
politicians and say yeah he or she is
saying this but they never deliver or
they never offer anything very simple
and tangible and what I'm offering is
the same thing that Australia offers
people to vote every national election
they have low turnout as we do in
California in the primaries and as I
said June 5th is everything we pick our
top two so we better pick two good
candidates that choose from in November
instead of just two identical candidates
so even if we have two Democrats I'm
sure I would be extremely you know I
have a lot in common with Gavin Newsom
as a fellow Democrat but I don't hear
him or anybody else talking about the
debt this way so what they do in
Australia to encourage voter turnout and
legitimize their elections is they tax
everybody $200 it's like a voting tax
and when you vote you get $200 for
voting so if you vote
there's no it balances out the tax or is
the people who don't vote take a $200
hit and so what I'm promising is that
everybody who participates in the June
5th primary and the November general
election that as governor in January of
2019 everybody who votes in June will
receive $200 and everybody who votes in
November will receive another $200 so
that's $400 cash on the Barrelhead
for everybody just for exercising your
civic responsibilities and voting and
you know I I want to help people out
this two to four hundred dollars you
know your millionaires aren't going to
care but a single mom with three kids on
welfare is going to care because $400
buys a lot of groceries it helps pay
rent you know that's a lot of money and
so I want to give a simple tangible
benefit if I'm going to save fifty fifty
to sixty billion dollars in my first
year and interest on the debt hunt a
hundred billion a year for four years
potentially and wipe out a two to two
and a half trillion dollar debt with
that fifty to sixty billion dollars of
savings in the first year if ten million
people vote in June and November that's
four billion dollars a lot of money but
if I'm going to save more than ten times
that yeah in order to get elected and
make that happen and make sure that the
special interests and politics as usual
doesn't clean up and the June 5th
primary with low voter turnouts we need
a huge turnout so I'm this is a chance
for people to get some help to encourage
them to participate
and and and you know I want people to be
aware of the debt issue you know and and
the $200 for voting twice $400 people
always say well how are you going to pay
for that
and then I could point to the more
nuanced and complex that issue which
really in a way isn't that complex but
so those are the things and and my job
as a candidate is not just to have a
good plan for governance which the debt
restructuring is about but is to win my
job is to win on June 5th to finish top
one or two so that I am on the ballot
otherwise I'm just whistling Dixie
so the $200 has put my money where my
mouth is
and and and offering that to people in
need and to voters that get out there
and vote on June 5th so we can make this
debt restructuring and and the rest of
my plans happen because you know I can't
defeat the gavin newsom x'
the other democrats and the republicans
on the ballot
just with good ideas i need to be a bit
of a populist yeah and and i you know
some people have questioned this as
unusual and but but i look at it as
helping people out as well in addition
to i need to do things like this to to
get attention i want to help people so
they can help me so that on january of
next year I can help them so I have to
win on June 5th I can't just have a
moral victory and say oh I ran and got
5% I know to finish in the top two yeah
to actually be able to make the impact
that you want to me now the I think what
Australia is doing is it's interesting I
don't know what's the best sort of way
across the world to encourage people to
exercise their civic duty of actually
going in voting and we should explore
what that is a lot of people that are
the libertarian would say that you know
just let people be let them do their
thing don't force them to vote don't tax
them $200 just so that they go and
exercise the civil liberty yeah but at
the same time the the general idea of
that's very interesting because it's not
a spectator support the democracy is a
permissive everything there's no 200
dollar tax here this is just not $200
for here what I'm proposing is no tax
$200 and the average you know most
people even very educated professional
people are fairly low information voters
they go on name recognition and very
simple things like Bernie's forgive the
debt or the president's I'm gonna build
a wall and make Mexico pay for it you
know it's very clear where those two
gentlemen stood and simplicity keep it
simple networks and 200 to to 400
dollars of assistance is tangible it's
simple and if that is coming with the
package of you have to be able to end
convinced that's the responsible piece
yeah you have to convince your debt
forgiveness to also work yeah that way
they get paid Georgia and I'm addressing
things like the housing crisis
immigration strangling regulations and
taxes all those other things are part of
my plan but I think the two high-level
issues have to be easy I'm the guy who's
gonna make the debt disappear and free
up 20% of our budgets
I'm the guy that gun it's the big story
yeah it's the big story and and but
that's kind of it's a bit nuanced and
there's a you know some people aren't
getting paid so it's a little edgy yeah
but the to to to to $200 for voting $400
total that's tangible that's simple go
out and vote and I'm challenging all the
other candidates for governor to sign a
pledge also offering $200 because I
think it's such a good idea
that I would challenge Gavin Newsom and
the two Republicans and the other two
higher polling Democrats to to sign this
pledge because if they don't I will
differentiate
myself from the crowd because some
people think it's politically just like
the debt I think you know it's political
suicide to mention the debt don't let
the voters know about that because it's
so embarrassing and nobody has any plans
to do it yeah and and this $200
traditional politicians you know some
people you know don't like it and they
find it disingenuous or some kind of a
scheme but you know we we we have to do
things differently and I have to do
things differently to distinguish myself
and you know I'm a problem solver and my
two problems right now are fix
California's fiscal problems that are
driving the middle class out of the
state nobody's left here but poor
homeless people in the very rich and the
the debt restrict restructuring does
that my other job is to get elected and
this $200 for voting in June and another
200 in November that is a way to bring
people out get assistance but also get
the people who don't otherwise vote to
vote yeah because I can't help
California if I don't get elected and I
am NOT a name I am NOT presently in the
polls so both of these issues are just
full of wins
everywhere with just a little edge here
and there so that's why they've risen to
the top of my plan the guy that's gonna
make the California debt disappear
mm-hmm that's good and the guy they'll
get you paid for voting YES so that's uh
that's good those are good strong
they're they they do they stand out
they're outstanding points you know
nobody else is doing them that's that's
how I know they're good ideas yeah it's
because the establishment won't go
Bernie Sanders is the closest person
that's had something like what you do
yes is is you know you know he's in some
ways my inspiration because he was
likable he has heart he cares about
people and you really can't say that
about a lot of politicians but that's
why I ran for president that's why I'm
running for governor is to help people
my intentions are altruistic I'm not in
this for ego or power or money and
that's what you get with an ounce
like a Bernie Sanders or even some
people looked at the president that way
you know that was a guy who didn't need
money he wanted to make the country
great again and had a vision of that
that probably less than half of people
liked but you know it was enough to get
him elected so we do have to think
outside the box cuz you know career
Republicans and Democrats frankly don't
and but but clearly it's been successful
with Bernie and and our president those
gentlemen you know Bernie darn near won
the nomination and and Donald got
himself elected you know obviously
people love or hate that man
with a passion but but these are
outsiders and we need a different way of
thinking traditional political thinking
is going to get you more the same and
this outside of the box thinking like
wanting to forgive the debt or wanting
to default on some of the bonds that are
purchased by hedge funds that they own
them maybe that is the new more
progressive sort of thought about where
we should move forward into the future
okay good you've opened my mind you
think you've expanded a lot of minds
into this into this new realm of of
thinking about politics in a way that's
like could we forgive the debt could we
invest that 20% of the budget into
education all these other things could
we get paid to vote all this great stuff
so and it comes from the heart like
you're saying it's coming from the heart
it's coming from but also up here both
both we need both correct and there's
been too much of neither and in our
governance in California especially so
that's why I feel called so check out
June 5th that's gonna be the the primary
elections in us in the in California so
check that out let's see if let's see
you know Griff for Gov mm-hmm so check
out Griffin where we will put the links
in the bio as well let's walk you
through a couple of the simulation
questions sure what do you think's the
most beautiful thing in the world I
think flower
star gazers which are lilies are my
favorite and they smell wonderful so the
smell of the flower yeah and just
visually I just buried my nose in a
stargazer I like receiving them I like
giving them yeah - especially the women
in my life and but I you know I thought
I was aware of this question and to me
that's that's the easier answer yeah but
I think the better answer is human
beings to me are the most beautiful
thing you know I think of my children I
think not just how we look how we are
physically but our capacity for love and
compassion is what makes us human so you
know i I've kind of left the world of
banking and engineering somewhat behind
and when I became a father in particular
all of a sudden people became the most
important thing to me and I think that's
why I belong in the Democratic Party
it's really the party of heart and we we
but we need to have the mind - yeah yeah
what do you think are some of the best
ways to maximize human potential
I think freedom and liberty but also
responsibility you can't that's there's
a famous I think Irish playwright who
said that you know liberty which is so
cherished in this country and its
founding and through today but it
terrifies people because it also implies
responsibility responsibility is
terrifying yeah but it's also where the
most satisfaction is in in life when you
take on responsibility as a business
owner as a parent as a spouse as a
friend as the son or daughter of an
aging parent there's nothing more
satisfying than helping other people
yeah like where it really counts yeah
that's what we need to do more of yes
that's what I'm looking to do in
Sacramento as governor of California
I love the idea of taking on
responsibility being something that
people feel empowered to do to exercise
their their freedom and liberty but with
taking on responsibilities of saying
here are the things that I want to do to
make the world better and I'm gonna go
and do them okay how about what is
something that you think is true that
almost nobody else thinks is true oh
that's a wonderful question I I'd have
to say there's a philosophy I discovered
and in in libertarian philosophy which
is an emphasis that all human
interaction is unique and you can't make
up a rule you can't make up thousands
and millions of rules regulations to
manage human behavior but I do believe
in the idea that that all human
interaction should be voluntary
consensual and peaceful and that there
should be no violence and no threats of
violence to influence human behavior and
most people agree with that but most
people are blind to seeing how much the
state does that either at the federal
state or local level so this country has
5% of the world's population and 25% of
the world's in prison populations so we
are at the bottom of the list of major
countries in human rights when it comes
to incarceration and so we you know with
the drug war that most people are in
jail for marijuana yeah they're using it
repeating over half of them so you know
if we applied what we all apply to each
other to the state any of the federal or
state or other governments I think we
would get better governance that is for
and by the people and so there are some
confronting ideas from that philosophy
that really challenged the status quo in
around things like taxation regulation
and debted nests and so I think we need
to challenge some sacred cows with
simple principle
like don't hurt people and don't take
their stuff and then the state and the
government can't do that either
because either they or most often
corporate or very secretive and rich
moneyed interests use the state you know
to rob the poor blind and and we need to
stop that we need you know to better
meet the ideals of democracy and freedom
instead of being you know slaves
essentially to to rich bankers and
corporate interests and they use
governments to do that so we need to
wake up in red pill to that a little bit
more and so my classical liberal roots
in you know you know the basically the
founders of this country we need to go
back to some of that and challenge some
of the sacred cows on both the left and
the right and just do what's right and
and take love and take care of each
other that's what we're not doing in
media and in government and in
corporations too we need to we need we
need to be more loving and take better
care of each other and we need some
people that's one thing that I learned
in Orlando in 16 we need better people
pursuing office and high office
especially because it's it can be a very
dirty business so we just need better
people we need a whole army of people
running for governors and presidents or
even city councils just better people
politicians tend to be these sort of
bottom feeder types you know the
personality is people people looked at
Trump and Hillary nor those I can't we
do better than these two so well you can
curse the darkness or light a candle and
I'm lighting a candle good on you Robert
for saying that thank you
yeah politics are the bottom two hours
yeah the bottom feeder resumed I would
like to think that there are people in
the political sphere that are there with
their heart and brain for the people
doing it really for that but then the
question always comes when someone
slides you that million dollar check
across the table what do you do then we
need strong people to
resist that temptation and that's the
whole conversation is why does our
political system function that way an
optimum optimize itself that way where
you can basically take a sum of money
and do whatever you want with the rules
so anyway that's a separate more
philosophical conversation but that's
also very very applicable to what we're
saying so how about we talk about the do
you think there is a meaning or purpose
to life that's a wonderful question and
I am in the vast minority on that
question and I the standard way of
thinking is you know what is the meaning
of life and been that the meaning of
life is sort of the core question and I
think a lot of intellectuals educated
and professional people ask but your
average person doesn't ask that they're
like I'm hungry and I want to eat you
know I want to go home to my wife and
kids they're they're not in their heads
they're in their bodies and so I think
you know whether it's Victor Frankel's
man's search for meaning or Monty
Python's the meaning of life I was
thinking the same thing yeah I there's
there's another notion that that I
learned from Joseph Campbell but he was
funneling the Buddha and and the Buddha
said life one interpretation of what he
said was that life has no meaning you
know what's the meaning of a flower
what's the meaning of a flea there isn't
any it's just there and it wants that
those things want to live and you're
there and you want to live and you do
what you what people are really
motivated by is not meaning meaning is
actually subject to something higher
which is the experience of being alive
the experience of feeling alive and the
experience of feeling the rapture of
being alive that's what drives people
not meaning that's for academics and and
and you know this is something I would
debate you know a sam harris or a jordan
Peterson on because those gentlemen are
incredible intellectuals that I've I
think we've all benefited from listening
to people like that but they're
intellectuals and and I would fall back
on the buddha and joseph campbell and
and what the common man except
variances which is not so much in our
heads but in our bodies is we don't want
to numb ourselves to heroin or alcohol
or watching Game of Thrones 48 hours
straight we want the experience of being
alive both the highs and the lows and
not to check out into this sort of
numbness yeah and I think meaning in the
way that many people have talked about
meaning is that falls under the
experience of feeling alive meaning
falls under feeling meaning is just a
feeling in your head like my life is
meaningful I'm doing valuable work I do
charity I support my family I have a
good time with my friends what are the
things that make people feel alive
eating exercising sex the satisfaction
of a good day's work getting rewarded
with pay that you could then support
your family with give to charity take a
vacation you know surfing is a visceral
feeling alive experience being on this
show with with you and Ron I feel alive
this is what I live for it's what I got
a bed for you know this kind of
interaction this conversation that we're
having about the state of California 40
million souls I feel alive when I go to
a concert I like rock music principally
but many other forms I feel alive when
I'm either in the audience or I'm on
stage singing because I sing as well so
that I think is what we all live for and
to an academic that may mostly be an
intellectual where it falls under
meaning but to me meaning is under
feeling feelings are more important than
facts the human experience of feeling
this this is I think the edge the
Democrats have over Republicans is that
feelings are more important thoughts and
ideas and some of the engineering and
economics bind you know like addressing
the debt which we talked about earlier
that's where you apply things like
science engineering
and I can't say that I feel that gravity
doesn't exist well somebody is free to
feel or think whatever they want but it
is a fact that gravity exists so then we
can feel it it's keeping me in this
chair so then that that is the argument
then it's not feelings make us feel
alive and they're incredible and we need
experience as many as possible and get
people excited about that but also facts
don't necessarily and meaning fall under
feeling because if facts fall under
feeling then you can fall into a world
where facts are absolutely irrelevant to
people's feelings right and that's not a
good place either so it's almost as
though they're kind of supposed to be
together absolutely you got to have your
facts straight Ronald Reagan a former
governor of the state
he said facts are persistent things and
we have to get them right or as close to
an authentic representation of reality
as possible because if your feelings are
based on facts that are out of line with
with such realities as gravity then
you're gonna have a hard time yeah how
about are we alone in the cosmos that's
a great question I don't know I don't
have a lot of data on you know I know
they're starting to find water and and
and at least traces of life but perhaps
was on Mars and I think it's an
important question and there's lots of
great science as well as science fiction
this is where I get most of my when I
think about life elsewhere I get that
from the movies and television to the
extent I still watch those things but I
think a more important question is are
we alone here and I very important thing
to me is connection and sometimes I feel
like an alien you know when I at a
political function I talk about the debt
or paying people to vote a lot of people
in the political and media world look at
me like that's crazy you know and and
then I feel a bit alienated or but then
I talk with somebody like
you are a lot of other people that I've
talked to on the street and they love
the idea so I think isolation and
disconnection is is one of our biggest
problems in this country and in this
culture so I think it's important to
stay connected emotionally to yourself
and other people because we're social
animals and so I think the question of
are we alone in the cosmos speaks to the
psyche the psyche saying I'm too alone
I want more connection in my life I want
more touch I want more positive
relationships and you know we don't
necessarily have to look to the cosmos
for that but it's a wonderful fantasy
and it's a terrific scientific and an
imaginative question it's a relevant
question but but to me the psychologist
to me hears that question and what I
hear is you know am I alone I'm I know
in my life and most people I know
there's too much isolation and
loneliness and not enough social
connection with friends and family and
the Bay Area's really who scores very
low in that so I get connection wherever
I can find it with my kids with my
friends this feels is this is a very
connective experience for me Ron chiming
into the conversation our producer and
so I I think that's the big problem it's
it's the disconnected person who walks
into a school and shoots it up so that's
that's I think a manifestation of
disconnection isolation and and
loneliness we're very grateful to have
had the connect team here yeah human
connection peace through doing things
like even just putting your you know
putting your hand up and just going like
[Music]
that feels good like that yeah just the
little things like this you know and
what and what just that touch does and
it feels good yeah it feels good and you
can look at somebody and you can just
really feel that palm to palm connection
so do you think we're in a computer
simulation that's a good I love The
Matrix
especially the first film trilogy is
great but the first film was just
fantastic and it's it's really I think
metaphorical too sometimes it feels like
we're in a soulless disconnected
computer simulation and again
psychologically I think that's where
that film speaks to the psyche is
because sometimes it feels like we're in
a machine instead of in a more
touchy-feely human Mammal experience so
yeah I don't think we are in one but
it's a wonderful vehicle because it's
possible we are it's possible we're just
batteries for the machine and the matrix
and this is a neuro kinetic simulation
that we're in but outside of that I
think that film is metaphorical to the
human experience of feeling like we're
in something that isn't really human
that isn't even real
and so I think culturally what I would
like to be just even for myself and my
kids and everybody is that we don't feel
like we're in a computer we need to be
warm fuzzy human beings and a big cuddle
pile we need more of that than this kind
of machines walking around in a big
machine trying to eke out a meaningless
existence warm fuzzy human beings in a
big cuddle pie yeah that's beautiful in
a big cuddle pile awesome and that human
connection that ability to stay
open-minded at concepts like potentially
taking our debt and forgiving it and
paint voters these are the things that
you care but you care about human
connection I I really appreciate having
you here I'm having you on the show yeah
that's my pleasure thank you thank you
Robert there's pleasure mr. Griffin
openig riff maybe one day hopefully if
if California is ready then ready for
you know frankly a golden age
potentially then then we'll get one yeah
and it requires just outside of the box
thinking and maybe you know check out
some of his links check out some of the
work see if it's of interest to you we
definitely highly recommend at least
considering becoming educated about
these different options of what it would
all entail thank you for tuning in if
you guys had a good time like comment
subscribe definitely share the content
with other people get them also thinking
about this how can we build a better
world and join us on patreon support us
the lights the internet the cameras the
action the safe place for people we
would love to love to have you join the
community and that's it we'll see you
tomorrow tomorrow we got a bunch of good
content as welcome and anxious so get
pumped whoo all right
[Music]
[Music]